will be our viewers will be wondering uh
the pictures that they were watching at
the moment and these are pictures that
we're just bringing in uh from northern
Israel uh following strikes uh coming
from the Lebanese side of the border so
as you're seeing uh extensive extensive
damage large fire uh this appears to be
the immediate aftermath of an attack
some kind of strike coming from the
Lebanese side of the border and this
speaks again to what our correspondent
Ali Hashem who was just reporting from
Lebanon was saying um this is what we're
seeing on day 27 of the conflict even as
we continue to keep a very close watch
on what's happening in that border area
between Lebanon and Israel there have
been exchanges there have been attacks
on both sides exchanges of artillery and
this is the
uh I'm just getting new information bear
with me for a second I'm told that
alasam Brigade is claiming respect
responsibility that's alassan Brigade
which is the the armed wing of Hamas but
this one based in Lebanon is claiming
responsibility for this particular
attack uh after it says having launched
12 missiles from uh again from Lebanon
that's what you're looking at We
Will We Will examine the aftermath we'll
keep a close eye on this we'll go back
to Ali at some point in Lebanon talk
about the aftermath of all of this I
want to just put this on a brief pause
even as we continue to watch it to bring
back in um our guest Eric Eric thanks
for your patience I mean you will
understand as our viewers will that you
know we're always watching multiple
fronts in this conflict um you were
telling us about your experience and
what your colleagues in uh in gaza's
hospitals have been um have been sharing
with you essentially you were telling us
that they have to do quick triage that's
what they're reduced to they have to do
quick triage of patients based on what
they believe
will be their chances of
survival yeah but the but this situation
you know when you do a triage this is
very much uh what what decides what your
choices is also the amount of resources
you have available and at the moment as
uh as they have limited uh access to
Anesthesia to vital drugs they have
limited access to electrical power of
course course that means that they have
to give up patients that they otherwise
could have saved and that's really a
very difficult situation for
professional healthcare workers I I want
to add another thing about my colleagues
uh at chifa and all the other hospitals
you know they are also lacking drinking
water water to clean themselves they
have they lack everything uh to sustain
their own health and well-being and they
report to us that now many of them are
getting skin problems they are getting
also diseases so this is really um
gastrointestinal diseases so this is um
this is becoming a almost hopeless
situation for them and I I don't think
this can compare with anything I have
experienced a cha before no look and
that makes sense because this is the
worst attack by far on Gaza the most
heavy bombardment and the highest level
of Destruction by far uh that we've seen
in all the Gaza
Wars Eric F thank you so much for
sharing that with us bringing us both
your experience and what your colleagues
on the ground right now are telling us I
want to go back to what we are watching
now and I'm going to bring in aljaz Ali
Hashem who's on the Lebanese side of the
Lebanon Israel
border Ali we are getting in a uh a
claim of responsibility by the alassan
Brigade in Lebanon that they have sent
uh some 12 missiles into Israel if
you're hearing me what can you add to
that well in fact alasan brigades Hamas
military Wing has announced or claimed
responsibility for hitting kadona and
other um Israeli settlements in the
north with more than 12 uh Rockets now
we saw the picture of the of the impact
this is not the first time by the way
that alasan brigades is claiming
responsibility for missile launch from
Lebanon they've done that for at least
three four times during the past 25 days
and in a previous uh occasion at least
few days ago the asion at least few days
ago there was a similar impact in a
residential area so what we are seeing
isn't unprecedented however the barage
today the big number of rockets that
being sent at the same time on different
uh uh fronts of or different sections of
the border is the is the significant
thing here because it seems that this
gradual escalation is heating up as
we've been saying before just before n's
speech tomorrow at the same time hasah
using the uh explosive explosive Laden
drones and Hamas today hitting katuna
with these missiles and these missiles
weren't intercepted by the Iron Dome
also hasah and whoever because now we
have let's just draw a bit a framework
for whoever is working on the Lebanese
front we have hisbah working on the
Lebanese front there is also alasam
brigades from Hamas there is also Al
brigades Islamic Jihad Islamic jihad's
military wing and there's the feder
forces that's the Islamic or the Muslim
Brotherhood Lebanese Muslim brotherhoods
uh military Wing so we have now several
groups groups under one umbrella
Hezbollah is the one in control here in
South Lebanon so this picture from here
is accumulating over the past 25 days
we've been see we've been seeing High
days low days also we've been seeing
days where hasah is announcing like 20
of its uh uh uh Fighters or 15 of its
Fighters being killed accumulating to
around 60 Fighters killed alongside with
several Hamas several Islamic Jihad
Fighters killed and most importantly six
Lebanese civilians killed over the past
25 days including three in the past 48
Hours Ali when you look we're we're
still looking at the pictures uh we see
a lot of burned cars damaged to what
appears to be a residential buildings
when those P there you go when those
pictures zoom out um when when you
consider the target we're talking about
the town uh the town of kirat Shimona
which is an Israeli Border Town Israeli
side of the border of course uh when you
consider the target the level of damage
and the information we have that dozens
of rockets were sent how do you assess
this because this is what you've been
doing for the past 27 days each time
there's an attack you have to ask
yourself well is this an escalation is
this more of the same what kind of
message is the Lebanese side sending to
the Israeli side or vice versa so how do
you assess
this well we have to take into
consideration the Lebanese front is an
adjacent front it's a side front but
this right side front is reacting in two
ways one way it's reacting to whatever
is happening in Gaza to the Israeli
incursion in Gazza to the Israeli uh uh
bombardment of Raza this is one side and
also the Lebanese front is reacting to
Israeli uh attacks and retaliation on
Lebanese side so we have here two layers
and on each layer there are many reasons
to see this happening but also as we've
we've been saying this is this has been
escalating and accumulating over the
past days so there is a message here the
message is that this is a new threshold
and the new threshold is taking us to a
new stage we've been talking in the past
uh few weeks about the stages and the
phases we've been in FA we've been in
level one and level one had three phases
the phase where we had the borderline of
2 kilomet depth on both sides then the
the depth of the front went towards five
or 6 kilometers then we went to a depth
of a front where Israel is hitting in
the Lebanese southest depth or uh like
14 15 16 kilometers inside Lebanon today
across the Lani river which is uh
according to 1701 the United Nations
resolution was an area of hostile act
activities andah or Hamas or whoever is
uh bomb uh launching Rockets from this
side is also hitting to the far to the
farther point for example of rospa in
Israel which is like 14 kilometers 15
kilometers from the border so that was
phase three of level one now witha
speaking tomorrow we might be heading to
level two what's going to be in level
two this is what we're going to hear
from Hassan nah he is going to draw this
framework and he's been doing that in
the past Wars we at least in in
comparing what nasah is doing today to
what NASA used to do in for example 2006
War we're seeing a pattern here he is
announcing a new thing a new Step so
what's going to be the step this is the
big question that I think it's the 1
million or1 billion dollar question for
everyone in the Middle
East Ali is he likely to announce
clearly this is step two this is step
three or are you looking more at sort of
tangential uh references and Illusions
uh I mean do you think he will say
explicitly what he intends to do or do
you expect more oblique references to
next steps for Hezbollah when Hassan n
speaks well most probably at least given
the past uh you know coverages NASA
tends to clarify some points and keep
other points vague so for example
there'll be some red lines that he will
clarify but there are other red lines
that we'll keep vague to you know give a
kind of a space of of safety for his for
his group for his people in order to let
the Israelis guess more and more about
this is this is a tactic and N has been
good in psychological warfare for
example before this speech Just few days
before this speech there was a clip from
hisbah a 12 seconds clip with nah just
passing aah flag that flagged to many
that there's something coming and that
nasah is going to speak and with nasah
speaking every one is is waiting because
we know this is a situation where this
group heah affiliated with Iran and this
resistance axis as they call it is in
control in several places the
geographical leverage they have from
Iraq to Lebanon to Syria to Yemen and
we've been witnessing in the past days
missile launches from Yemen so this is
becoming Regional even if it's not yet a
regional conflict in definition but at
least if we watch it from far it's
becoming Regional no absolutely and
that's why we keep looking at these
specific pockets of territory around the
region one of them is where you are and
have been since pretty much the
beginning of uh this war and look Ali
I'll tell you what we're seeing because
you can't see the same pictures
obviously right now but we're seeing um
pictures that were shot just moments ago
from Kat shamona now that's just a few
kilometers away from the Israel Lebanon
border clearly uh the rockets that were
fired by by alasam uh Brigade hit an
urban center so that tracks with what
Israeli Channel 12 is saying that dozens
of rockets uh they're they're talking
about a direct hit in kot Shimona and
that's exactly what we're watching the
aftermath of that so they hit multiple
cars we saw the um the firefighters and
we heard the sirens as First Responders
and you see the flashing lights they're
the sirens uh as First Responders are
now at the scene uh attempting to put
out the fires so hasm was giving us all
the uh all the context around that this
less than 24 hours before Hezbollah
Chief Hassan Nala is said to speak uh
from uh Lebanon tomorrow so we will
[Music]
um Ali I see you're still with me okay
so that's the scene it is now 1600 GMT
it's 6:00 p.m. where you are some
viewers will be joining us just now can
you just recap what has happened in the
last hour or so less than that where you
are for people who are joining us
now well we start with the impact in Kat
Shimona on the Israeli side of the
Border after the kalasan brigades
hamas's military Wing in Lebanon
announced launching 12 Rockets towards
the uh Northern towns and and cities in
Israel now as you were showing on the uh
on the screen there were there was an
impact maybe several impacts now we
don't have a clear picture of number of
casualties whether there are casualties
especially that the Israeli Army over
the past weeks have announced this area
as a a military area and asked many
people to leave now this is one second
thing which was very significant hisbah
using explosives explosive Laden drones
in attacking Israeli positions in South
Li on on the on the south libanon border
this was significant because it's the
first time that this element enters the
front line between Lebanon and Israel
also part of this whole context of
rockets there were several rockets
launched today towards several positions
maybe six launches towards six locations
on the Israeli border including one here
where we are in nakura and the sounds
were really huge different from the ones
before and we didn't really re see any
kind of interception this is another
thing also there's an issue that is that
should be taken into consideration as us
saying n is going to speak tomorrow also
we have three Lebanese civilians who
were killed over the past 48 hours now
you were mentioning the Katona impact we
have to take into consideration the
Israelis have been the Israeli military
has been hitting several residential uh
homes here in Lebanon so there are
several Lebanese houses that were hit on
the border whether in M ja whether in
whether in so we're talking about
several places so this also could be
part of the whole equation of the bigger
equation and as we said to tomorrow Nala
is going to speak Nala is going to put a
price tag on all
this Ali I'm just going to run our
viewers uh through the pictures we have
two sources of pictures right now it's
16 GMT 1800 in local in the region what
you're seeing were pictures from a very
short while ago after uh a rocket attack
from hamas's alasan Brigade The Lebanese
base wing of the alassan Brigade and
what you're seeing now is the live
picture of that area in Kat Shimona in
Northern Israel so the fire has now been
put out that's what it looks like live
right now the fire has been put out and
now we're getting a clearer sense of
where those Rockets hit um it was
clearly some kind of commercial urban
area you see civilian cars that were hit
that were on fire you see the uh First
Responders the firefighters that are on
the scene that have now successfully put
out the fire that's the aftermath and
top right of your screen is what moments
ago was still happening when the fire
was still burning Ali before we move on
from this um again Hassan nasala the
leader of Hezbollah speaks tomorrow he
has not spoken directly correct me if
I'm wrong on this but he hasn't spoken
publicly addressed uh the nation and I
should say the region since the
beginning of this conflict
correct yeah that's right it's been more
than 25 26 days since the beginning of
this conflict nasala has been silent and
his silence was described as suspicious
because everyone was waiting nasala to
talk to draw the red lines from the
beginning but seems Nas just had
this decision to keep the situation
going on towards accumulation just as we
are seeing and it's not it's not a
coincidence that 24 hours before he
speaks the front line is heating up this
way and hisbah is using kind of
different elements different weapons
Hamas is using maybe stronger uh
missiles from the Lebanese side of the
border so this is just kind of setting
the scene and he is setting the scene in
order to say well now we've done all
this and now we are on the maybe on the
verge or this is a threshold for a new
level a new phas each of these fighting
groups and you named a number of them
that are active on the Lebanese side of
the Border whether it's Hezbollah
whether it's the Hamas um uh hamas's
military Wing Islamic jihad's military
Wing uh you named another as well each
of these military groups have their own
forces yes absolutely they have their
own strategic
considerations on
balance do we assess do experts assess
that Hezbollah is Keen to open a
fullscale war or not at the
moment
well it's clear uh SEL this is going to
be a long War of Attrition at least this
is what we can say as observers as
reporters covering this war it's going
to be a long War of Attrition just in
case as it's been said that in Gaza
there's going to be a long War because
this is linked this is kind of
organically linked and with these groups
functioning here in South Lebanon no one
can function in South Lebanon without
hb's consent and no one can fun
away from H's umbrella so there is a
clear umbrella here and at least there
is a kind of analysis that all these
actions are choreographed so whoever is
doing something is coordinating with the
other side and at the end this whole
picture of escalation is kind of setting
the scene and drawing the bigger picture
and this bigger picture is aimed at
sever at signaling and we had this
discussion before there are signals
being sent from here there are signals
sent to the Israelis on one side and
there is another signal sent to the
International Community to the United
States in precise in specific now this
is the first time s that Palestinian uh
groups are functioning from South
Lebanon since 1982 1982 Israel invaded
Lebanon in order to expel the
Palestinian resistance from Lebanon and
that at that time the pl was here and
they were they left to Tunisia and since
then there were only Lebanese mostly
Lebanese groups functioning from the
Lebanese border except for some uh uh uh
some cases now this is the first time
they're functioning completely open
everyone knows about them and under hisb
Allah's umbrella so it's a a picture of
an axis hasballah Iran the Palestinian
groups whoever is with them in this axis
that they call the axis of res
resistance is signaling a message that
there is a possibility of a wider
conflict in case allies off Israel
didn't stop it from continuing its war
on Gaza so will this have uh ears to
listen or it will fall on deaf ears this
is another question because you know
sometimes with such contained situation
contained tension as the one in Lebanon
things might slide gradually and it's
sliding gradually even if it's also a a
calculated sliding and we can see that
it's a calculated escalation Rules of
Engagement are being updated on daily
bases so ifb is sending Rockets or Hamas
or whoever orb is using new elements new
weapons Israel is also doing the same
thing Israel is now using war planes at
the beginning there were no use of war
planes now Israel is using them
extensively it's using drones ex
extensively hasah used its drones drones
for the first time but we wouldn't be
surprised to see hasb using more and
more drones especially with a lot of
allegations to Iran of supplying Russia
with with drones uh explosive Laden
drones so why not hisbah having such
drones like the Shahs in Lebanon and
being launched towards Israel so it's
it's actually a a big question here and
everyone actually is is in the state of
of uh uh wondering and questioning and
concerns are high especially for people
living on the border it's not an easy
situation to be we are now in a border
Village so just like 2 kilometers behind
me is the Israeli position and anytime
the Israelis are shelling we can see the
shells falling in the space between us
and the Israeli positions that's within
the 2 kmet depth so it's not an easy
situation we are journalists we have to
do that but for normal residents for
Farmers for Shepherds they can do that
and in a country that's going through a
lot of economic hardships and people who
are bankrupt government that's bankrupt
there is a very big question over the
you know how people are going going to
cope with this situation no absolutely
look what you describe and what you say
makes a lot of sense Ali with people on
both sides of the Border you know who
would who would like to uh lead their
normal lives and that has become
increasingly if not totally impossible
with everything that we've been seeing
over the last three weeks I think the
key word in what you said was the
calculated sliding part and that's why
every day you're explaining to us you
know what we're looking at and what it
means and does it mean escalation or
does it mean that it's this weird kind
of status quo that we've been seeing for
3 weeks Ali thank you so much for all
that context all those explanations